Mr.
Santos's constituents go to Washington.
Dozens of residents from embattled
Republican Congressman George Santos's
New York
district have taken a bus
to the nation's capitol
to demand that he resign
I took off from work to come
to a personal day.
So go to Washington and ask
become a party to hold Mr.
Santos accountable.
It is pretty embarrassing.
The daily barrage of just
these lies.
I mean, who is representing us?
I feel like
this is a
some kind of storybook character
that that's scamming us and laughing
because we're being scammed.
I happen to be a Republican
and that's why
I'm really disappointed
in the Republicans, especially because
it stands by this guy literally
and figuratively.
Let's bring in CNN's David McKenzie.
How is Congressman
Santos responding to this?
Yeah, so, Jake,
I was up there where you are today
with the residents
as they were trying to get some answers
from Congressman Santos.
He wouldn't
come out and speak with them, though.
It seemed like
he was in his office at the time
earlier today.
He suggested
he would,
but he later told CNN
he would correspond with them in writing
and sort of seem
to make light of the number
of signatures on the petition
that they delivered to his office.
Take a listen.
I look forward to welcoming them
and having a thoughtful discussion
with them.
At what point does
this become a distraction, of course,
and why would I not talk to them?
That's their freedom of speech, right?
Now, entertain
a conversation with them
every single day.
I represent them all equally.
And there were really a wide
range of folks up on the Hill today.
I met one woman
and she told me she works
with Afghan refugees
and has a lot of sensitive information
about their whereabouts
and would not feel comfortable
working with Congressman Santos's office.
Another constituent, a Republican,
telling me he's proud of the gains
Republicans have made in recent years
in New York
and that Santos really compromises that.
And that was just universal
frustration, Jake, with House
Speaker Kevin McCarthy
and a real sense of disbelief
among some
that this can happen,
that there are so few mechanisms
really available
to remove a sitting member,
no matter how egregious the lie.
Yeah, I mean, the list of lies that Jorge
Santos told to get elected
is too long to go through here.
But it's
practically everything on his resumé.
One of the most egregious
is that his mother died
because she was at the World Trade Center
during the nine 11 attacks.
It's not true,
but he's made that claim many times.
And amazingly,
his guest
tonight is going to be a firefighter
who actually was at the World
Trade Center on Nine 11. Is that right?
Yeah.
Santos has long suggested
that his mother died
of the residual impact
of caught up in the cloud of nine 11.
And what we found was that immigration
records show
that she wasn't
even in the country at the time.
That firefighter
though, Jake
Michael Weinstock
evidently thinks that the issue of nine
11 first responders receiving
adequate medical care is worth.
The association with Santos
but it's coming at a price for him.
He lost his job at a law firm
as a result
of agreeing to be Santos's guest.
Oh wow. All right.
Eva McCann, thanks so much.
Appreciate it.